so you have all these swipes and it's
still a free app yes what's when what do
you for now so exactly what is that
going to change what are you thinking
well so our core offering that you have
right now is going to always remain free
at least at least that's the plan and
next month actually we're going to
release a few premium features that
we're totally excited about it's it's
you know it's it's two things that our
users have been asking for for very long
time and we think there's a great
opportunity for us to introduce these
features and and because we're confident
you the values there and users are
willing to pay and it adds to the user
experience where we're going to charge
for any hints and what that might be I
there's a I will say this there's there
are there are tender hacks as our users
call it you know we always tell us that
they use tinder for all different
reasons that were not the original
intent for example when people travel
they they match with locals to get
recommendations on where to go and what
to do and we think we can there's an
opportunity to enable and support some
of the tinder hacks but actually charge
our users for that value and and that's
what's coming early
and you mentioned travel for people to
you know find locals find you know kind
of the inside scoop when they're
traveling what and put in is obviously a
lot people use as a dating app obviously
yes yes you have obviously plans to move
beyond dating or dating kind of like the
bread and butter and so you know our
vision from day one was to solve sort of
a core problem that we that we see with
the way the way people get to know
others which is there's always somebody
you want to know like in this room I'm
sure there's somebody that everyone
wants to meet but you're free to go up
to that person because you're about to
get you'll you're afraid of that
rejection or the potential of rejection
and then for the Peter you know there
are people who get pursued a lot and and
that experience sucks for them too
because they're constantly getting
pursued and
have to do the rejecting and they have
to serve like like run ho hey and when
people come after them and Tinder's
Tinder's was created to solve that
friction and when you look at that sort
of dynamic it exists in all kinds of
relationships where you're trying to
meet somebody new whether it's romantic
business friendship and right now we've
been focused on the romantic part of
that story and it's it's you know you
can imagine where tinder you where you
can apply sort of the philosophy and and
and the the environment that tinder is
created to a variety of different
categories and when you're coming up
this new premium model why now you've
been a free app you know no revenue
model yet you're rolling it out in
November why is this the time so you
know it's the test for us was would we
do this even if it didn't make us money
is it great for our users and you know
we have this road map and we've only
really accomplished like probably a
small percentage of what our ultimate
vision is and the things that we're
launching next month are all part of
that that value proposition that we want
to give to our users so it's great for
our users it allows us to make money to
sustain the company so we hope and I
think it's a win-win for everyone I mean
we need we need to keep the company
afloat and and sort of make money to
reinvest into innovation and and and
help build great things that our users
are asking for and you know IAC is a
controlling owner
yep tender have they been putting a lot
of pressure on you to to make money or
giving you some direction or you know
make pushing hard on the revenue figure
no I think no more than any other board
member would put on a CEO I think it's
it's a question of you know what what is
the right timing and does it sort of fit
into our long-term goals and I think you
know we all decided as a group that that
you know this is the right time to start
to to start to introduce revenue and by
the way you know these are we're not
turning on the faucet all the way you
know this is we're getting our feet wet
by giving users something that they
really want
and there's just a great opportunity for
the company and for the users because we
you know we get to finally find a model
that can sustain us into the future and
the users get what they've been asking
for what percentage like Spotify ever
examples done a pretty good job on
taking you know freemium members and
push them to paying do you have a kind
of goal and what percentage of the
current users you want to see switch
over to B I guess would be tinder power
users when they have these new
capabilities yeah you know there's
there's we have an internal goal I think
it's like too early to comment on on how
feasible that is I think we're we're
pretty confident and in sort of the
value of what we're offering and and
that it solves some problems that users
have with our with you know with their
experience and and with what they want
to do in their lives and I think I think
as long as we do that and sort of focus
on on the user experience and delivering
value then then everyone's gonna be
happy
so after this revenue comes out what's
what else you guys working on you're
you're very lean but forty employees yes
we're forty now we're we're gonna need
to grow in order to hit our goals for
2015 so we're 40 going on going on
bigger but what's next you know I think
I think it's 2015 is a lot about scale
for us there are a lot of things that
we've wanted to do as far as improve the
product in various areas but we haven't
gotten around to doing it just because
we've been focused on sustaining the
growth and you know making sure the
architecture can scale to the demand
that we have and you know when you're
going like this there's you know you're
you're fighting so many battles
simultaneously and now we can finally I
feel like take a step back and breathe
and now start to really improve on our
core experience beyond just making it
fast and work but also create those
incremental those you know perfect the
edges of the user experience and offer
new ways for people to meet others offer
better tools and you know improve things
like messaging and you talked about
scaling so you know tinder started as a
kind of a side-project hobby yeah
and it's obviously grown to become a
social phenomenon I think yeah what how
did you guys go from you know a
side-project
app to this crazy scale the crazy growth
that it's like international growth hum
there's there's probably 1,000 answer
share question how I think you know if
you ask me I think it's having a great
team that was able to quickly respond to
the challenges that were thrown our way
along so I mean it's it's we grew very
fast on some prototype code was it viral
no it was instantly I think within the
first month the amount of usage we were
getting not only was was was tinder
growing at a faster rate but the usage
for the for the user base was just like
beyond our wildest dreams so like we had
a lot of users who are very very active
that creates a lot of strain on their
systems it you know forces us to quickly
architect the system in a way that can
scale and respond to that demand and it
also you know when you're when you have
this much you only have this passionate
audience it becomes very difficult to
sort of prioritize because there's so
many opportunities and how to like
filter through the noise and like you
know say no to like 99% of the things
that you could do and focus on you know
what is that what is that one thing that
you got to introduce the user experience
that will benefit users in a meaningful
way what advice do you have for this
crowd in terms of if they're out - for
marketing for example if you want to
make a product that's gonna go crazy
obviously it's hard to do but any
marketing tips any design tips I know
you're a big design guy yeah I think
well I think it all starts with really
understanding what is the problem that
you're solving I think too many people
start companies and don't really define
that the the problem and who their
customer is right they just sort of are
alert of this idea of building an app
and and and they don't step back and ask
what's the point and what's the purpose
and I think once you define that for
yourself you know as a group of
or as a founder you're able to recruit
great minds that believe in that vision
and you're able to communicate that
effectively to your audience right and
they people do attach around those
messages well we found is as great as we
were at sort of mobilizing this this
group of international marketers who can
help spread the word
ultimately it was solving a problem that
people had in our ability to explain it
that kept not only the team together but
kept the audience together so I think
it's really important to define that and
perfect that day one
the sooner you perfect that the the
faster you're going to be able to go as
far as recruiting and explaining your
value proposition to your users and grow
faster while we're talking on values
obviously you guys just went through a
pretty you know nasty sexual harassment
suit worth the status of that now and
kind of what you know did it do to the
company for better or worse so status we
we settled just we you know we wanted to
put everything behind us and move on and
focus on the company you know look
there's a there's a story that the world
has heard not from us but from from
others and you know we just sort of
decided to step back and focus on the
company and not get into any you know
back and forth but you know there is
another part of the story that nobody is
heard and I think the the you know what
added to the company is the team was
present during the time in question and
they saw everything and you know proof
is in the pudding nobody's left the
company and and we're more focused and
more motivated than ever and I'm really
proud of the team and I'm proud of you
know everyone and how they they sort of
powered through a tough time but yeah I
mean we're stronger than ever and what
did you learn from that in terms of a
lot of people here assembling teams they
have founders co-founders all that style
what would you have done differently or
kind of what have you changed after
going through that I think it's hard
when you're when you're starting a
company especially one that's growing so
fast
everyone just automatic
they become so close because you're
bonded by this common vision this common
goal and and and you're going through a
very tough time together and it's hard
because you become so close that it's
hard to sort of create boundaries but
every company needs to have a
well-defined division of labor everyone
needs to understand their roles and have
clear expectations and and there's got
to be clear boundaries and sometimes you
know sometimes it's actually a tool not
to have that because you're so close and
you're able to sort of work those long
hours and like and power through the
hard times together but you know what I
would have put a more of an emphasis on
not that we didn't do this but I would
have took me our cares to sort of create
more clear boundaries within the company
and I think that would have created more
clarity and prevented some of the
confusion that that you know came up
recently listen and so you guys are
mobile yep you're you know photo-based
this is like you have you check off all
the boxes on what's there's a
gamification it's everything that's kind
of buzzing now every you guys you guys
have what do you kind of see in the in
the market like what's exciting you what
do you think is kind of gonna be huge
what do you think is gonna kind of be a
flop so this is gonna sound self-serving
but it's not I think I think the last
ten years last the last decade or so has
been about defining the social graph and
then finding you know kind of picking
out and defining who your friends are in
social media and then being able to
communicate with them and now that sort
of we've been defined and and trained to
define ourselves as how many followers
we have there's there's the next decade
of social which is about using that to
expand your graph and and venture out of
your existing group and I think the next
sort of trend and the next topic because
this is what users want not because
there's a bunch of people who are
building and this is what users want is
to meet others and to expand their
network and to be more social and
companies like tinder you know I hope
that you know tinder is gonna be at the
fore
of that movement but I think you're
gonna see and you already are seeing a
lot of companies popping up that are
helping you discover those around you
and it just so happens that that
discovery is something that's a very
real-world problem like all of us in
this room like know like probably very
few people know everyone or know a
meaningful amount of people in this room
and that's a problem right you should be
there's so many opportunities in this
room that are just sort of have been
have have been swept under the rug and
and I think there's gonna be there's
gonna be I think that's the next sort of
problem to solve in social and that's
what we think about all day long I mean
we think about how do we create tools
that reduce the barriers involved in
social discovery and then add a little
bit of fun on top of it besides tinder
what other companies are doing this and
other what other companies do you see
popping up PC you I mean you have the
kind of the dating photos like now do
you see other yeah needs I think you
know you you you're you know you see yak
yak and that's like all about sort of
fostering communities and giving people
voice to be noticed and you're seeing
jabber that's sort of allowing is
connecting people based on jobs and you
know there's there's tinder for business
even the app the app that you know the
under 30 app that a lot of us I mean
I've been surprised how adopted this app
has been at the conference and that just
shows you that there's this desire to to
sort of understand your environment and
your surroundings and who's there and
what opportunities are Florida to so
they're you know there's a lot of
companies and even you even see like
snapchat with their their recent college
you know kind of creating creating
stories around colleges well that's very
much about bringing together groups of
people who don't know each other but but
can connect around a topic or sort of a
a theme and I think you're gonna find
that a lot in the coming years you're
gonna find companies that are gonna
perfect that it's incredible I mean with
what 1.2 billion swipes a day you guys
must have so much like incredible raw
data yeah what are you finding that
surprising
is there any kind of cool what are you
learning about humans through through
tinder like your favorite fun tax I
think it's it's one thing that we've
learned and I don't know if this is as
much quantitative honest way to
quantitative as much as it is
qualitative is that we're actually very
good at understanding the nuances and
details inside photos so at first glance
you're like oh Tinder's all about looks
because I'm looking at photos well that
is a very superficial understanding of
tinder I think you know you look at
these photos people are doing things in
the photos there's body language their
stories that they're telling and our
brains can pick up these nuances in
milliseconds
and and you know it's true what they say
a picture's worth a thousand words and
what we're finding is that one of the
that the most powerful signals of
relevance within tinder is actually the
content inside the photos and part of
what we're trying to figure out is how
do we capture that information and then
use it and feed it back into the
recommendation engine and create more
relevant matches for people can you have
to you have algorithms that read the
photos I can identify things so that's a
little too you know we don't we don't
talk about sort of specifically what we
do just cuz they don't people to game it
but we we we look at a variety of
factors and you know we'll look at your
graph we look at what you're swiping and
what you're you know what you're swiping
left to what you're swiping right to and
like you said it's a lot of information
you know it's billions of data points
every single day and it's a it's a very
complicated and massive feat to take to
actually make sense of that data and
then make it actionable for the for our
users so it's it's something that it's
something that we constantly focus on
besides using the data to make tinder
better is there plans or any ideas -
would you monetize the data somehow
whether they're advertising or and some
sort of because you have such a trove it
it finally valuable no I think you know
were were we've been day one very
adamant
that that are the data that we get
belong star users and you know we would
never monetize it nor to use it in a way
that I think violates their their sort
of their rights and privacy's so you
know I think we'd be that that is a it's
something something that we think a lot
about and I think we've sort of they
internal the philosophy we've adopted is
to sort of take very I would say a very
conservative viewpoint on the data that
comes to tenor and in terms of photos
you have any any tips for the best
tinder profile photo now yeah
besides it besides a tiger besides a
tiger which is ban now tinder bans Tiger
phone no no not tinder the the
apparently New York doesn't allow you to
put I don't know where people go to get
these tiger photos it's it's it's
amazing but no my tip is be authentic
and be yourself again it's not about if
you just keep thinking like people can
actually figure out these nuances and
these details like people can call
very quickly by looking at a
photo so just be authentic and be
yourself it's just like life you know
it's like Justin Justin my partner
always says you know pickup lines don't
work in life why would they work on
tinder well being fake doesn't always
work in life either we can see through
that so I think why would that work on
tinder either tenders are big reflection
on life
speaking of fake and that what in the
tech world right now is you think it's
overhyped and is maybe gonna fizzle if
there is anything general themes I might
ask you to call I think I think
wearables is a very overhyped
because I think they're there there is a
we're not working when we talk about
where their wearables we're not working
back from a problem that we're trying to
solve for customers we're sort of moving
forward with defining these different
technologies that can do cool things
that can understand my movement but what
is what is the like what is it that the
user wants to do and I think when you
think about it that way
there's the
the things that we're creating or
setting foundations for that but
nobody's really sort of took the tool
sets and created a story that resonates
with users you know look at Apple watch
and great it's gorgeous it does like but
III don't know why I need it you know
it's very easy for me to take out my
phone are they trying to save me
literally two seconds of my life I mean
I I but then when you think about the
possibilities as far as all of this
coming together and giving me a clearer
picture of my health and giving me
actionable metrics and and giving me
actionable data and what I can do with
with that that's the piece that's
missing it's like great you're giving me
stats that's great I don't know what to
do with that I'm not a doctor but if you
actually tell me and give me tips I
think those those will be the
applications that actually leverage
wearables in a way that could be very
meaningful to society but right now I
think it's in its infancy and I think
everyone's talking about it but but
nobody's really talking about the
purpose why we need this is there gonna
be tinder for the Apple watch yes yes
it's coming we have we have tinder for
they and for Android wear already which
is such a fun experience that was you
know is a fun fun project that the team
worked on and I think you know we'll
probably probably is like a hackathon
internally put together tinder for for
Apple watch just you know just to see
what happens
she swiped the watch back and forth yeah
it's I think it's a fun way of using
tinder I think you know in that case you
know if it's a question of whether or
not people will adopt the watch which
you know we have it's yet to be seen if
they will then we want to be on that
platform we want to deliver tinder
wherever users want to experience it and
the watch could very well if they sort
of solved some of the consumer
applications around it could be a viable
platform to the you know same goes with
you know the the rift and wearables it's
just I just don't you know these there's
a lot of great technologies out there
but I'm not seeing the applications yet
the creativity on the application side
is coming but it's not there and
and hopefully as people are opening
these tools up as platforms developers
can get start getting really creative
and build some cool on top you're
mentioning people have tinder hacks like
they use it for what are something like
the most interesting way ways people
using tinder that most kind of like off
prescription that you're surprised by I
think one of them's while they travel to
get local recommendations another one is
is generally I would say we hear all
these cases where people are using
tinder outside of native that's that's
like but there's different there's
different ways than that that sort of
materializes whether it's using it to
get local recommendations when traveling
or trying to make friends because you
came to new city or just trying to make
friends period and you're like there's
we're doing business we hear all the
time that people are cutting deals on
tinder and and you know whether you're
an artist trying to get your music out
there and try to get fans like the
people use tinder to get more followers
on Instagram by sort of putting there's
all these various hacks and it's great
cuz you know I think it shows you that
we've built an awesome ecosystem and you
know at the root of all of that I think
when you've built a great product people
learn how to leverage it further than we
ever imagined and I think we're now
learning from our users and those hacks
to sort of find the next opportunities
see when I told my wife I was an
interview you she said that she would
murder me if I downloaded tinder so but
that's obviously I think a lot people
feel that way like if you're in a
relationship and you're on tinder it
might send the wrong signals or there's
not a stigma but people can't like it
used to be it's official if you're in
relationship if you have a you put it on
Facebook now the new thing is you're
serious about someone when you delete
tinder from your phone so how are you
gonna get me not murdered if i download
tinder like in terms of what how do you
convince people in relationships that's
not just for for dating so you know i
don't think we can I don't think we have
that
but you know like I said there are a
variety of reasons you want to meet
others romances is a big reason it's not
the only reason and you know it's we
explore the other avenues where you can
apply tender I mean we don't have any
immediate plans to launch anything there
but it's always sort of it's something
we constantly think about when we think
about sort of what is the longer-term
vision and plan of tender you know but
like here I'll give you an example again
not you know to use this conference as
an example I mean how cool would it be
if you can swipe everyone in this room
and get a little bit of information
around them to make the decision on
whether you want to meet them or not the
issues that tender solves and romance
exist in just general discovery it
exists in this room right you can apply
it in so many different avenues you know
we're not you know we're not just here
to find somebody to spend our lives with
we're you know we're here to also
socialize and and and do other things
when it comes to making relationships
and you know we want to be at the
forefront of all new relationships not
just romantic